Yeah, I'm drinking cucumber
water right now.
I can't believe you got me
a four-handed massage.
Like, I've never
even heard of that.
That's-- that's way
more expensive
than anything I would
get you, trust me.
I have to go, there's
like two creepies here.
Hello.
Hi.
Do you guys need me
to clear out of here?
Are you Amy?
Yeah.
You have a four-handed
massage, yes?
We're your therapists.
I'm Noel.
I'm Gunth.
( both )
Namaste.
Would you excuse
me, just...
One minute?
Hi, I'm--
I'm sorry.
Do you have any female
therapists available?
I think I just assumed
they'd be women.
No women today.
All of our lady
therapists
are home with
period cramps.
They synchronize
their cycles.
But you're in
for a real treat.
Before we get
started,
are there any injures
we should know about?
No, nothing I can
think of.
You have no problems
with your shoulders,
tummy, booty...
No.
Elbows, ankles,
ta-ta's?
None of
those things.
Everything's okay.
We'll just give you
a moment to disrobe.
How much should
I take off?
Everything.
We wanna touch
all of your skin.
( quietly )
All, my skin...
We'll be back
in just a minute.
Okay.
( knocking )
Are you naked yet?
No.
Wonderful,
we're coming in.
Jesus!
Nice.
Nice what?
I was talking
to Gunth.
He's doing
a wonderful job.
Are you tight?
You seem
really tight.
Are you feeling tight?
Okay, are you talking to
me or each other right now?
( chuckling )
Okay...
Now we're gonna jam
on your lower body.
Crazy.
Her legs are
exactly the same.
Okay, what are
you talking about?
Your legs.
Oh.
They're the exact
same as our niece's.
Okay, I'm really
having trouble relaxing.
Would you guys mind
just not talking?
Maybe like just
putting on some music?
Of course...
we're sorry.
( chanting )
Omm...
Guys, guys...
Guys, I know that's
just you singing.
We're not singing.
We're not.
( chanting stops )
Oh, sorry.
Take another
deep breath.
Okay, you have a severe
knot in this muffin top
and we're gonna
work it out.
Okay, how many hands
are on me right now?
Shh...